it's tough it's like are you sure you
want to go get such a sense it gives no
no I'm gonna pick my unity so are you
really ready for that bro
are we moving a shaking shaking and
moving Tim busy sng listen gigs Ltd 27 I
like that
SMG 27 28 we just said I just asked you
I was 28 and you were like yes 20 years
listen g27 waste man 28 ah monster pop
tradish rough my corona every every
monster I've bought I've scrubbed it
wiped it every one I bought I am what
you call it Dairy Milk yesterday whole
nut it had dust on the on the packet
look I put it in the sink watch the
whole thing I can't take risk like yeah
welcome back guys as per you know
patreon subscribe to that so wait is
this we buy exclusive content on there
we've got a video on there now we're
gonna have another one on there pretty
soon sir bro see if you just download
the patreon app search shit's and gigs
yeah man you can be entitled to so many
new things we've got four different
tiers each tier have different rewards
per se and if you select the last tier
which of the 14 you get all subsequent
tears involved yeah man makes sense yeah
we had a couple people jump on this we
had a couple people Jamba that was road
work Sebastian you examine came clutch a
little cheeky little comment on the you
cheer was our IG and he just popped up
that being he's supporting the show he's
supporting the show and then we've got a
be shower a be happy jumped on she saw
the little free panting so let me up
let me up attendees of you if you're
watching this man like a bee came to say
what's that that's free plan from let me
spot days man 10 let me give you 10 away
the rest you [__] you're not doing
nothing
listen minimum is free the minimum one
is free pound so that's three pound a
month so that's 10 P a day you got wrong
you were there oh yeah that's not how to
work out I was about to say you've been
thinking nah that's not good at Tempe a
day from P a day
you spend more than that every single
day giving my my free up your one he
[__] cut and run me my piece one me
my piece because we do me we've been
doing this for 27 weeks you owe us fill
me that's hilarious actually on a real
like there's so much good stuff you can
get on our patreon we've obviously got
the merch come in but you know as the
carbon 19 is happening it's slowing down
the process nothing it's in the works
designs I saw see the denied are the
designs are saucy so Abby don't worry
you'll get your 50% off painful brush
that's another thing yeah if you don't
if you subscribe for the patreon and get
the second tier you get 50% off our
merch one gram so you know so Abby she's
the first customer ten pound yeah yeah
the rest of you guys the merch will be
up soon and then we can well you can we
can look after you by looking off the
rust Gangnam um as you can see we're
rocking the hats today well God
necessity more than anything because in
a [__] haircut bra my trim my current
trim this Cove in nineteen that's just
let's just dive into that let's dive
into this coronal so you thought you had
Corona when in December let's talk about
that first you ma'am if you remember was
the episode 14 with Jacob banks yeah and
I had to leave I had grown in nineteen
he had rode a night scene in nineteen I
had run a one night in 2001 nine he must
have thought I was dying I was dying and
I had all the symptoms symptoms go
hallucinate if I'm gonna say my fever
was tight so I had to bounce so I have
to come off camera give these man to it
I went upstairs got in bed and I had 12
hours of hell I couldn't breathe I was
my whole sheet I had to change the whole
sheets of my bed because I sweated
through all of them I did not have to
change bed oh we have a spare room in
there Wow so I had to change bed Wow go
into a different rate I'm almost having
hallucination that role a ghost family
in go brother role is the worst it was a
better ride in my [__] life that's my
[__] hate it um that must have been
Corona that must have been early onset
early onset corona but you know it's
funny I was sure I mean to
and it literally said like who else out
there thinks they had corona like back
end of xix not that embarrassing because
that's me cuz that was me I'm convinced
that it I don't think I've been tagged a
touch with my white blood cells our arms
house so but they're saying that 60% of
people are a sim to Mike Oh 60% so 60%
of people that guy don't even know no
God you know they'll have it yeah that's
crazy but then a few other men are just
dying mmm no just uh a dying brother
went to I went to test Cody everday yeah
and these man so first of all I had to
queue well that Cuban thing is had to
key for about 15 minutes to get in oh
really yeah
and then once I got in I had to queue
again to actually get into the main shop
because they've introduced a one-way
system around the entire supermarket
yeah so I'm going around the supermarket
one waiting yeah and I was so furious in
the fact that like people were taking it
too seriously not too seriously I can't
say taking it too seriously but people
have taken it to such a degree that I am
forced to so we're going up this one-way
aisle when Donny to people in front of
me is looking at oranges so the [__]
behind him stopping because to me a to
me a like gap which makes me stop yeah
so I'm waiting I don't even want oranges
yeah I don't want anything in desire
yeah yeah I'm waiting and then finally
he moves and then I realized I went out
background down the other I realize I
did want something from the aisle
couldn't turn around I had to go around
her I was furious because I remember
when you said to me the first time you
had to queue for Tesco everywhere it
wasn't thinking right that's because I
had to reach out of money yeah I think
it now we're still calm think that the
next day or two days after at secure so
vet Road when I went to LD so it's cut
you off when I went to our D not lash up
every like two or three shops ago I went
to Audie the way people look at you they
look at you like you've got poison fam
like you've got [__] poison I would
burn out that same shopping trip same
dropping Jim I was walking down the
aisle i sat after one waiting for what a
sock talkin before with it I need to get
one e to get so I'm going down this
woman's coming up she grabbed the side
of the aisle
and she she took a double bracket she
slammed the back against it was at and
because I just have a dress I'm always
wearing shorts long socks whatever she's
drinking he's got it yeah because he's
lounging he's lounging he's been at home
for weeks he's going but it's literally
flooding it's like cancer
it is terrified of it airborne cancer
people are [__] petrified
everyone's got poison apparently to
everyone else hmm but funny enough when
I when I have to walk close or walk past
people that too in close proximity I
hold my breath yeah I do it like
alternative singing out loud
yeah yeah yeah I'm not doing it the
other day I went for a walk on the way
back I was crossing road like crazy mmm
because in the fingers I didn't bump
into that many people but someone's
walking decide that path it's like small
yeah so I'm like crossing the road
oversee someone's coming out so I'm
across some riders right and it's weird
because it's normally you're like you
can't yeah it's a bit like it's a gray
area are you being a [__]
I governor the top you do the most right
like he's weird Mondays all quizzes um
proper orchid I don't know I don't know
what the [__] to do what the [__] to do
your owner is sending me on demand I'm
not gonna lie to you not that I've got
Corona but like the the stay in our home
thing is it's long how long this is the
third this is week three for me anyway
this is week three I think is week three
yeah I've been thinking weed free for me
but yeah man it's [__] it's houseful
but I didn't know where to stop my work
obviously you haven't been working no
but my work is working is worse than
working yeah because literally
especially before what I do the work has
died down the loss there's actually not
that much for us to do yeah but I still
have to be on my laptop all the [__]
day you have to be bit so I'm just
sitting in this chair with [__] to do
and I'm watching youtube videos I don't
want to watch yeah I can't go for a walk
I can't do nothing I'm sat on my sofa on
my laptop like waiting for some way to
do probably dead like it's [__] dead
I hate it and then I've been wanking
like there's no tomorrow
bro I think everyone's wanking fingers
gone up like oh there's gone up through
to read pornhub drop that premium team
straight on I logged immediately on
that's funny I've not even used it bro
it's not that much better but there's a
few gems in there
because now I can see I can see the
appeal now they've given me the free
trial can see the appeal yeah because
you log in and when just scrolling
through the videos yeah if it's got like
a star next to it it's a premium video
so I'm only watching premium videos now
like I'm not settling for any less
DePrima less be rough so I'm on there a
couple of them are decent a couple of
them are decent I think it's run out
there's only for a week yeah it's run
out now but I can see the appeal for
short if I had so much expendable money
yeah I would do it but I have to buy so
much [__] before I can bring myself to
pay for porn yeah to pay to physically
pay for porn that's a step that is the
step because then you have to fat
religiously you just have to get you're
paying for born yeah yeah I don't think
I could see money come up my account I
go to pornhub I don't think I could see
it but never people yeah some of the fam
there was a day there was a day I must
have bashed like three times just out of
sheer boredom yeah just cause it's
nothing to do decide to do Yahtzee just
get out of the way yeah it was annoying
me bruv
I didn't even want to do it I was like
I'm bored I'm just [__] yeah it's
more of it was more of an ax sits more
of a necessity than a want yeah yeah
which is weird yeah yeah because
sometimes I just want to like but right
now I feel like a half the way just in
your past the time Konami wish in the
days away from and speaking of porn I've
been watching haircut videos like
they're porn you know I mean when you
see someone there's Bob was galore
yeah yeah at the minute and when I'm
seeing then just that fresh fresh fresh
blade I'm looking at my mouth is
drooling from jealous jealous my hair is
nap stock and I was thinking on the way
here today I was thinking like bro
beam this is a time where being black is
actually long because if you're white
imagine if you're white why I'm blonde
mm-hmm
you can just like how do I say
it's cuz I've been watching that Viking
anime as well you can just be out here
growing hair looking at Thor yeah you
can just go like you know when you see
man I used to like how do I explain it
you know when you watch a movie as iron
and a man has been out on a mission
Roy's been through some hardships and it
comes out the jack yeah yeah yeah way
looks bangin just pop in hair down here
put up an allotment or something the
lumberjack and beaches are just not as a
man from when I come back my head is
like a microphone my cool majors I don't
like a [__] I look like a [__]
rapist associate murder serial killer
icon
[__] Bill Cosby I can't do it the
front the longer your head is the more
of a [__] you'd as a hundred percent
one hundred bro so yes it's not it's not
here for us this is the one time where
they got their bored people right now
I'll win him there laugh panache oh god
man a la orden naturally bore people or
people that cut never help itself that
has bowled you guys are laughing right
now you guys had a true MVPs you are cuz
you just shitty enough is change Killian
your lifestyle wasn't changed I'm not
doing my hair right week four for me now
I'm not having a haircut I was in denial
when it was all coming to a head and
they're talking about like to close the
businesses and all this thing I was
convinced like my Bob was gonna do home
gigs Yeah right
I don't yeah I was thinking the last
time I'm there I'm thinking he's gonna
give me his card uh his number anyway
it's gonna be like cool hit me up when
you need to trim I'll come I just
assumed that was 108 gonna have hasn't
happened at all
and everyone's that are we gonna do
about your barbers in my head I was like
I'm gonna be fine gonna be but he's
gonna keep cutting my hair he hasn't
heard from him he knows exactly the
situation I mean I haven't [__] heard
from him I'm buying a I'm buying a
clipper in the next two weeks and I'm
gonna I'm gonna shave my own thing
you'll see it soon guys you're gonna
look Islamic
Oh God massive did that's funny Islamic
you know that's funny
needs to be done man I'm tired bro it
doesn't need to be done I'm just so
scared oh yeah but I'm gonna watch fade
to do if anyone's got a nice fade
tutorial that I could look at and study
tell me exactly why I need to do what
length and what head size and all this
talk tell me exactly what I need to do
and I'll do it because of what keepers
at home yeah got the right attachment
yeah I've known on Instagram now there's
lots of adverts for Clippers just I
don't know it's not every one my one I
don't know why cuz I'm not search for it
well obviously they can probably listen
they know what I'm saying in it yeah
listen to me all the time so every time
on Instagram every time I say sir I want
something your pops up on Instagram like
with the adverts so I'm gonna buy I'm
gonna buy when I clip it saying like $27
it comes from America rah so what what's
the timeframe of it I don't know
delivery's brother I've been out Aaron
Amazon they're telling me estimate
delivery time was like 1st of May
oh wow it's ridiculous wow that was like
last week is it's literally crazy but
yeah man I don't know do you kind of do
you kind of feel like Corona is I feel
like I see in one or two ways if kind of
feels like a black mirror episode or
like hey what's that other show there's
another shadow money heist so imagine
imagine okay let's think of it as money
heist I've never seen my heist in my
life like it's money heist like I said
about bail on Netflix you don't see
money guys the Netflix I've seen the
trailers and stuff is it foreign yes in
Spanish I've seen I've seen the picture
or video I watched it now oh my god
watch it no no no mother's watch it I
guarantee you people don't listen to the
episode now we'll tell you to watch it
swear down money heist is banging also
good cool cos sober never heard anyone
speak about it ever really really but
I'm so surprised him money high seas
[__] dope I need star season for his
[__] dog
alright it's not better than ozark in my
opinion but money I stole alright pepper
the reason why I say this kind of
reminds me of money highs is because in
money highest they use distractions
it's a robbed stuff obviously they're
robbing banks it yeah yeah so I was
thinking imagine people around the world
have created coronavirus to distract
everyone so everyone has to be at home
so Amanda might just go into banks of
robbing [__] why would that would be in
it deep deep sit now imagine if that was
actually the case someone is someone
somewhere in China has gotten like let's
say 10 or 12 operatives in different
continents in different countries of the
world and they've really lost sleep
alone they've just released coronavirus
to the world they tested it in China
first as a bomb it works they've
released it to the rest of the world
everyone is at home and they're just out
there robbing [__] the dots have been
connected um Razia my affair she was I
went for a walk I'll say to you I went
for a walk yesterday I didn't see 50
people well hot Sunday I did see 50
people
the streets were barren town was family
you're not allowed out I couldn't
believe it
every day I get in my car my heart beats
I've seen your John to my brother's
house the other day I had to bail him
because my brother's got a gym in his
garage so I've been training there every
day so on the way there he's like
15-minute drive from me
so it's a minor yeah obviously that's
not technically a central travel yeah
yeah yeah but he's isolating I'm
isolating I'm going to his garage he was
very back but yeah um as I pulled up
onto one Street one policeman was behind
me in it Oh God I'm not my heart's
beating I'm telling ya
no it's minor I'm just like now just
fine ting I'm not fine finally fast
so yeah I'm driving there I'm just like
[__] our [__] now is what behind
me [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] another keen
boy you're literally not allowed out
yeah you're not it's a wild time but the
thing about it is this is like wayward
thinking this is not even something I
truly believe in by thought is an
interesting concept yeah in that getting
political with it now obviously this is
the first time in anyone's lifetime yeah
that the government have actually taken
upon themselves to use their authority
to such a degree that they've told any
everyone in an entire country you ain't
allowed at your house you
that's North Korea kind of take yeah I
know they've said in an entire country
England fam in the UK you're not allowed
out not allowed that and then they've
got policemen patrolling patrolling
saying stopping people on the street and
pulling people over on the motorway like
where are you going you're not allowed
out
so obviously it's in the best interest
of everyone
yeah I'm not saying they shouldn't be
doing it they should is in everyone's
best interests um but moving forward
when they really want to get something
over the hill yeah and they like once
you've popped the cherry cherry pops
yeah there's no cake it realize like we
can do we walk in control DS man I want
like if I if this is the way I want
things to go yeah then it's gonna go
that way in it like Riley actually
stayed home he wasn't thinking right now
she's laid hope there's no one allowed
out that's what it's cannot sing and
because I told boys Vignan Russ on my
desk I told these my don't leave and no
one leave me he got sucked off that
night he got sucked off that night man
when our cameras hit don't [__] leave
he were that's your child
Boris BJ Johnson horse-feed a does fam
he taught his government get on your
knees [__] get your [__] knees you
know I am you know a much total whole
country to stand your [__] on do you
know what else this reminds me of hmm it
reminds me because I was saying this on
my walk yesterday that because obvious
you could hardly see anyone cannot see
anything it felt like it felt like we
were living in Avengers with Thanos
snaps a whole nation were gone
bro this is endgame inning this is
endgame you're actually is anger this is
n this is literally endgame
wild this she thought oh snap would have
half the population or gone Oh family
cuz no one's rats are barren well it's
well worth left
no one's about he's actually a wild no
one's about it's [__] great this is
dom be apocalypse and you know as might
as well i don't know i don't personally
know a single person with it personally
neither do i i don't know a single
person with it all it knows ages elbow
guy and he didn't even get any symptoms
that's all I know is he drove itself or
going that was the first black one I
probably was the diverse back
to get it that's funny but like the way
certain people react about it
Suites me like certain archetypes for
like that the mentality that you would
assume from a certain country and the
way they've acted around it makes me
laugh in just in terms of like like
South Africa for example I think they
had when everyone's like obviously here
we are like a thousand or a couple
thousand deaths and then Boris was like
you know we can't do this anymore
you man are gonna have to stay home
because this is not banging yeah South
Africa had 400 cases zero deaths I never
liked normal even they odd note no one
died in South Africa when I would lock
in the board is no one's coming in Osama
know everyone's in your [__] house it
just sweet me because I imagine the
South African being like no no we're not
moving and the same with who was it
Germany yeah Germany are doing the best
in Europe mmm because they just said no
lockdown yeah now and they were like
brother would you mean close what do you
mean I can't go work on dude I don't
care
yeah stay the [__] home but no one's
dying here brother and we're gonna keep
it that way the [__] home that's funny
and you know do you know another not
really I want to say it's a positive
it's just a thing about Corona obviously
coronavirus itself isn't a positive but
making people stay at home has made I'd
assume anyways made people think outside
the box because I was saying this to
Bella
like if it wasn't for coronavirus a lot
of people wouldn't be at home one like
during the day or whatever during the
week and then a lot of people wouldn't
be like on YouTube looking at our
podcast and looking at you know I mean
that's why we got that growth from but
as well a lot of people still are trying
to find ways to make money in the
coronavirus trying to try to find their
own talent or from me she'll find the
road dude I mean it's a good time for
you to think to think like when I said
to you I said I think I said on podcasts
of a while ago when I used when I used
to but whenever I've made like funny
videos or something it's because I'm
bored at home and I've got nothing to do
yeah I'm always my most creative one I'm
a
yeah of course and it's I think it's
definitely been like a wake-up call
where people are at home or [__] all to
do yeah and they're like let me just do
something let me just figure out
something and there's it might even not
even been something that they have
before they wanted to do yeah they're
just getting into sighting enough I just
want to see him [__] online class is
here video [__] fitness [__] here and
[__] business page here and people
are so in [__] and knitting [__] and
start there all everyone trying to make
money everyone home in it and it's
probably also a wake-up call where
anyone who usually works in our offices
at home yeah
myself included and they're probably a
lot of people I'm sure thinking but if I
don't want to [__] work in an office
yeah working in an office it's [__]
boring yes Amy I've been screaming for
years now people are experienced in it
thinking oh is actually [__] like I've
been waking up five minutes before my
shift every day I jump in the shower
where I'm on the computer I'm kidding
like I'm around my family obviously it's
dead being stuck at home but they
probably thinking right this is a life
like I wake up one eye one eye work do
my normal work and go for a nice walk
and this has happened you just when the
weather's gonna start getting nice as
well and they're thinking I'm getting
paid the same I'm not spending any money
on petrol like I eat healthy I'm at home
all these things and they're like I'm
getting jobs throughout a house done
like why the [__] am i working in a dead
dark horrible office all day every day
with everyone breathing all on me the
track [__] in my ear yeah when I'm
getting the same amount work done [__]
in a hundred home yeah and I get way
more work done at home yeah even
sometimes bro I come but I ain't doing
[__] but I still get more done than I
would in the office because you can just
kind of dedicate yourself and blah right
I've got this to do
let me just bang it out and by the time
of half an hour of being left alone and
just smashing a well my whole days doc
yeah just keep banging out yeah rather
than this whole eight hours sitting in a
[__] chair at [__] desk sitting next to
someone you don't even like wanna talk
see you don't even want to talk to you
bro if you want to be left to [__] alone
you're just counting down the hours till
five o'clock til I can go and then
getting this long ass traffic home from
the home commute like people are gonna
realize already saying the way to do it
this home thing is where we won't be
doing it it's where it's the whole thing
is right you want to be doing that you
make your your money elsewhere
do you know why also I've noticed due to
corona adverts have changed okay yeah so
you only ever see now there any adverse
you ever see obviously NHS adverts dead
bingo adverts because there's no Sports
shower or stuff you can get in
supermarkets swear down like then we
would never see an app us you know vote
for a restaurant or baby like on the
phone like t-mobile Oh - and all that he
depends of your country or whichever
country you listen or watching this from
but you won't see a restaurant advert oh
you won't say poured all the funding
from those won't be any like clothing
adverts Mike you don't really see a
sauce you've already so whatever got you
won't see them anymore because of no one
spend the money because no one spend
money or advertise it because it's
because we're closed
everything is locked it's mad it's mad
is so mad did you do your Clapton
everyday Clapton Oh 8 o'clock yeah
alright the NHS Bob alright I'm not
standing on my doorstep and for copy I
collapse window I'm not clapping
anywhere for who's hearing me they're
all a work the people don't have been
for Kearney like that if you were the
judge sing ISM in my head yeah I was
thinking obviously everyone's outside
clapping yeah the people who work for
the NHS that are at home yeah and and
they look around feeding their habit for
me that's so awkward and you're clapping
as well and then if they know you were
for the NHS do you think because
actually think I tell it like my
next-door neighbor works for the NHS
okay she's a midwife okay so obviously
she's not already on the frontline or
whatever I don't know what I don't know
if she's doing any extra [__] whatever
they're obviously she's sitting out
there clapping and she's thinking more
captain [__]
but yeah the whole I don't know the NHS
ting is a weird one a weird one just in
terms of like how do I describe it
people I've seen people's reactions like
I don't know how to word it in terms of
obviously like you've got the one side
of it where people are obviously being
extremely grateful all the hard work
that they're doing and stuff like that
and I rate that highly and I also rate
people who work for the NHS for people
who don't I rate a rate the aspect of it
of like we need to make a conscious
effort to make it easier on the NHS to
manage everything that's going on
because obviously there did move all
these Coronas things and stuff like that
fam if you get stabbed if you're walking
shop and someone stabs you like they
would normally would yeah it's long you
know it's long for you now no one's seen
you yeah it's more dangerous now where's
your bed where's your bed because
everyone's busy yeah truth that's where
the main problem is yeah is people
because obviously all the other diseases
in the world are still going it's still
going although the murder and all the
accidents people fall in the front brake
and Alec all that actually it's still
happy to go happening but then we've got
all this influx of Corona as well and
that's where the strain comes in yeah so
that's what I mean the people like when
they're like big man please stay home
because when it's impossible for us to
work under these conditions
yeah yeah ray it yeah but then there's
another side of it where I don't know if
it's necessarily coming for people who
directly work for their chest obviously
everyone's different but there's for one
side of it I feel like there's there's a
gray area of entitlement that I'm seeing
from like I saw like a policy of a day
and someone reposted it and I was
thinking why the [__] you be posting
that it was like someone's who someone
whose mum works for the NHS and it was
like ah I just think it's funny how
everyone thinks are let's clap let's
support the NHS now when all this stuff
is going on but my mom's worked for the
NHS for the last four years and no one's
ever clapped for a before Norman's I
mean this is like big bang your mom
chose to work for the energy what you
want about yeah like this is what she
gets paid I'm pretty sure she's
compensated for what she does but what
are you talking about like is it
obviously it might sound harsh but it's
not like she volunteered yeah it's not
like she's it's not like someone just
said like Liz we need you we did we need
your skills and talent get in the NHS
you're gonna be working ridiculous hours
and you're gonna be underpaid for it
but we need you you haven't got a choice
yeah and she's out here saving lives
understandable if that was the case
cause that's not the case it's not the
case is it Liz wanted to work their
broth
like I just like it's all good I don't
understand why people are getting all up
in arms about it but you know what's
also obviously I don't
obviously I don't work for the NHS I
know a few people that do work for the
NHS all working on schools and stuff but
what's weird is that obviously because
of Corona we what the government needs
at a either more volunteers would be
people that don't necessarily work in
specific sectors that deal with corona
NHS it's a common bollocks yeah yeah but
the weirdest thing about is obviously
prior to corona or there were obviously
legislators or there was there were acts
trying to get pay rises for the NHS yeah
and the government would obviously say
no yeah yeah and now I don't see there
was that all that deportation talking
like the immigrants and blah blah blah a
lot of non English people they work in
Nha they work in hospitals and stuff but
these are the people that were in the
front line now trying to save that are
exiting tsunamis that brexit takes crazy
label turn your IDs African care without
me because you can't you I'm
volunteering I'm not volunteering cuz
James we need you on the front line no
it's your mom's business brav here's
your mask could deal with these no no no
no no no I salute you mum yeah yeah I
salute long looks like long I couldn't
risk myself like that yeah see jokes
aside man you guys are risking a lot to
save save the nation and iris I only
respect that so so to you guys it's
proper to you everyone in an age has
everyone helping out you know well one
team one dream kind of take money or you
guys are paving the way and making sure
everyone stays safe so yeah man up we do
love that see wouldn't do rate as to you
guys what is one thing less whenever
this is over it's gonna be over
hopefully soon but when all this is over
the quarantine Blair over what will you
miss from being quarantined oh that's a
different kind of question of what
you're gonna say what's the first year
I'm gonna do is I know what will I miss
about being quarantined no good question
couple things one is my [__] petrol
yeah I'm saving on petrol of saving and
I'm
still been driving places even I
realized so I spent far too much money
on petrol far too much
what will I miss about being quarantined
probably you know I'll miss I'll miss
the feeling of being how do I explain it
I take things I clearly take a lot of
things for granted in my day-to-day
mm-hm and I'll miss I'm gonna miss
wanting something so basic to my life
yeah one thing as bad as I want it now
I'm gonna miss the feeling like
obviously I've been training in my
brother's garage and stuff yeah and he's
got a little piece of equipment here in
there we make we make do of what we
could what I would give for my gym right
now yeah you have no idea yeah by a week
after a reopens I'm not really gonna
give a [__] cuz it's gonna be normally
and I'm still gonna have days work today
and I don't ever want to feel that way
again because I would give anything for
it now yeah anything same it would make
it would make my [__] day day if I
could bear like if I can't have my gym I
could happily sit through any quarantine
as long as it takes as long as I've got
that one release every day where I can
go to the gym for an hour to train hard
as a person have a laugh whatever and
then come home and like my jujitsu as
well I'm missing like crazy like if I
could have that Old Firm the quarantine
for as long as it takes but when I
haven't got that and I'm like right need
to exercise and I'm going to [__] my
brother's carriage and it's just like
the last few weeks I was freezing in
there and it's just like [__] this I'm
trying to get motivated to do it and I
can't and I'm just like what gift for my
gym yeah I'm yeah I'm gonna miss a but
one thing I'm gonna miss about being
quarantine this is like having is is no
longer taking things for granted I know
it's easy for people to say like oh I'm
never gonna take this for granted again
you will you will you will give it I
give it four [__] days I give it four
days and the novelty wears off on
anything yeah trust me
but yeah where are you I would know i
would miss
as much as I much as much as I'm bored
out my mind like I'm gonna low-key
losing it I would miss just chillin with
Bella yeah you know I mean because we
can we can stay in and chat all day
listen to music watch a movie have a
spliff you know we can there's so much
we can do we can cook we can chill and
when I'm back to work and she's back to
like everything there are weeks where we
work opposite shifts or whatever and I
see her on Monday but obviously I see if
right the week but we don't actually get
to chill till probably Friday yeah you
know I mean and it's like we [__]
live together yeah bro that's mad yeah
that's mad hmm and we can't even just
[__] children talking just have a day
sometimes we chill for an hour by I know
I need to go to bed cuz I'm up yeah the
quality time that you have a home is mad
like I remember so many times well
obviously I would see when I was growing
up like I would see my dad on weekends
yeah and then we'd have a great time
with my dad on the weekend and I used to
I don't know I used to feel like a
little bit jealous but not really
jealous cuz I had a sick I I enjoyed my
childhood with my dad
and how would this our was with my dad I
never once wish I'll [__] leave I
wish I live from my dad
yeah but hasn't growing up I'm realizing
brah if my dad wouldn't live with me
because my dad's got two younger kids
now yeah it doesn't matter if you're a
part-time dad or if you're a weekend dad
or a full-time dad yeah your weekend out
period you do not see your family but
when you're working full time you don't
see your [__] families that you wake
up before pretty much before everyone
else wakes up especially if you've got a
job in London you have to commute or
whatever yeah you wake up before
everyone else wakes up you get back
before after everyone's gone to sleep
yeah you don't see anyone and you don't
spend you definitely don't spend any
time with any timeline and so I reckon
there's bear people that definitely the
people that have to commute no longer
commute into London and stuff and I
haven't all this time with a family they
must be thinking [__] hell yeah I
never see my kids ever see my kids
missiles so much like there's a manager
at my spot that left pre Korona not
preet like that was grown was happening
but there was a lot done wasn't enforced
and he left probably let's say a week
before a lockdown and a message him like
[__] because he was going to start a new
job obviously no one's hiring at the
moment like [__] what you gonna do like
you were capable well I messaged him and
he was like you know what I'm having the
best time because I never get to see my
kid oh do you know what [__] kudos
that that warmed my heart and I don't
like this stuff you take for granted
sometimes nwg the crazy double-edged
sword about is that he's doing all of
that for his kids yeah but he never gets
to see his kids bro marketing actually
sure
spend time with his kids just brat do
random Shannon like you know what
[__] props to you man props
thanks I rate a rating that highly
[__] sick bro yeah it's crazy man I
reckon oh I reckon a lot of things are
gonna change a lot of things I reckon
there's gonna be like a big push I
reckon he is gonna be eye-opening thing
in terms of like more people should be
working from home oh right this in
general because it's really bro we did a
test one so before this whole thing blew
up mmm we did a test run right at my
office so in my office the way my job
works is obviously I work on the flown
suite to clients customers whatever well
we work in the house building industry
so I'm speaking to like solicitors here
builders here if I can just normal
people sometimes all about a million
different things yeah and we deal with
email emails as well and our emails are
blacked up mmm like backed the [__] up
yeah like they'll we're always behind
because we just get so many emails every
day and everyone's trying to tackle a
million different things and one email
might take 10 seconds to fix one mmm
won't take two hours to fix so we're
doing doing doing doing doing and
obviously that's our day-to-day we had I
think we were like three days behind on
emails and stuff like that so my head of
the department cause the sword and she's
like right cool this is what's gonna
happen with all this Korona [__] there
might come an opportunity where a time
well we're gonna have to close the whole
building and we need this is way before
the lockdown
yeah it was like we need to know that we
can actually still run as a business
while that's happening so tomorrow
everyone take your laptops home do
everything everyone's gonna be working
from home and we're gonna see if we
manage it
wherever the pitfalls are we'll know
we'll know next week how we can fix my
rope it was very small
various never thought that rope is very
smart the contingency plan was very very
smart so we all did it
Pham came back to work we had as a
business we had been far more productive
at home then then then work yeah order
in worked up all the emails were done
yeah everything was done Noda strikes no
distractions everything was done and we
had to turn the obviously had to turn
the phone system off they've set it up
so we can actually have a phone system
at home now
but they turn the phone system off when
you were doing the test when we're doing
the test run and there was a voice
mother basically said email us yeah
because the phone system off we're
practicing throwing away wherever and
everyone I think we had like two
voicemails we were expecting to come
into like three thousand yeah like what
the [__] going on this and that from
they listen to the voicemail send us an
email because everyone was tackling all
this stuff yeah Bank cleared out
everything there was no distractions
everyone was so it came about to work on
Monday everyone was blessed and they
must have been like rah rah
well we pay for this building for brown
because it was working better at home
yeah
and obviously since then the work slowed
down a lot but yeah everything's working
better from home everyone is probably
happier but they're probably a little
bit down because they're not really
having so much social interaction
especially people that live alone
there's no change of scenery yeah
exactly but apart from that like I
reckon moving off to this people are
kind of thinking rah more people should
be working from home or you can split it
up have some more flexible time I think
a lot of business owners people who run
big companies they're gonna be thinking
right
this is gonna be [__] for some people
but like we need more automated services
because I'm too reliant on manpower and
power I've had to send everyone home and
my business is [__] like no one can do
any was the youth I was telling me about
the Amazon market a supermarket a
supermarket brough speak about people
can know what's probably gonna come yeah
bro so cameras on I've got a supermarket
now I think the first one isn't
Australia I think I might be wrong but
it's there's one open now there might be
a couple open that basically if you've
got an Amazon account if you if you want
to use this supermarket it has a facial
recognition thing so I'm assuming you
set up the facial recognition beforehand
and you just go through
and you just walk it there's no one that
works in this supermarket no one so you
go in all the food stocked and the
camera they got hundreds of cameras in
there so they run your facial
recognition access your Amazon account
when you walk first walk into the shop
they monitor everything you pick up
while you shop in put it in your basket
or whatever and then you leave and then
when you look at your Amazon account
you've got a charge for how much your
shopping cost and then you just pay on
your Amazon account and it's donal you
don't have to talk to a single person
you're they're mad
it's Corona heaven it's a corona heaven
just mad those Jeff Bezos is he's cocked
it beforehand you know and there's so
many people with everything and we
should have done that because this is
not working this is not working and so
that in terms of like automated working
there's gonna be so many companies out
there like well probably needs to make a
change because that was so far god
forbid this happens again
the people that will suffer will be
hospitality and leisure yeah that that
sector because because of this now I
guarantee every business was gonna have
a contingency plan mmm they're gonna
have to put a contingency plan just in
case something like this happens again
hundred-person gonna need to because no
one foresaw this I mean I never thought
this would ever happen in my entire life
you want to think of it no more dreams
but business is like let all small
businesses about that's like not really
like family-owned businesses a lot of
them they they're run up seas as it says
family-owned businesses and they run
Monday to Sunday so those are the kind
of business that will suffer as well but
there's only so much we could do man
it's gonna be tough times overcoming
this as well as going back to normality
and god forbid it happening again
because what's the stop it from
happening again exactly there's nothing
stopping it and the thing is as well is
such a you know like how do i how to
explain it
there's a phrase that I was listen to
one got another podcast I listened to or
says is the juice worth the squeeze so
as always like people have always known
something like this is possible to
happen but the the plans you need to put
and the measures you need to put in
place are so extreme it's almost like
especially when you don't know if it's
gonna happen or not it's like what's the
point what's the point in doing it is
the juice worth it it's not it's not
worth my time and effort to plan for
this thing because it
it's never happened in anyone's lifetime
it could happen is very it's very
possible and now it has happened but in
previous people have always known it
something like this could happen
but life's just not worth it it's the
amount of effort it would take to
implement these these failsafe is just
not worth it
like the amount of money I'd have to
invest over the years to prepare for the
three months that might be our business
it's just not [__] worth your perfect
example is likely in America the most
houses have not most houses but you can
opt to have a lack of doomsday bunker
thing just in case talking about yeah
not a lot of people but a lot of people
that think about these things have like
these bunkers and stuff yes there's like
a war breaks out brother and you have to
go underground so a lot of people buy
supplies Bayona this and you know just
in case by it's a very few slimmed I've
got that but god forbid that happens
they're calm there's something I've seen
that these foresaw the Apocalypse
junkies are blessed right now but it's
the joy thing this is why human beings
are a joke myself included because
exactly what I just said about the
novelty wears off yeah the people who
have built their own [__] bunkers in
their back garden and they've got years
worth of food and water stored right now
they're like haha haha ruff I plan for
this and now I'm blessed
yeah once it's over they're still going
to be preaching bunkers and everyone
will still go back to normal and black
but [__] [__] [__] you like I don't in
their blood or me with Corona happens
again is like Brooke I just don't care
sorry I just don't care enough I can't
be bothered with a bunker I'm not
investing thousands of pounds and buying
hundreds of pounds worth of food and
water to having this secret bunker in
case it happens again you've already
warned and intend you assign me what
happen again and everyone was so blah
will do we've done it before dude a day
before would do it again it's fine but
anyway we've got a new segment for you
guys this is what we're gonna run from
now on keep things funny and interesting
and I like it it's good am I the [__]
so we're gonna find little clips might
say clips examples of people giving us a
situation or not us but given a
situation and we're gonna decide if
who's the [__] right so the first one
that we've got for you today this is
from
and so this is a reddit page I love it
so am I the [__] for telling my
girlfriend it's not fair for her to
complain that I'm facetiming my son
every day for 45 minutes I already know
who's the [__] here oh I already know
so read it again am I the [__] for
telling my girlfriend it's not fair for
her to complain that I'm facetiming my
son every day for 45 minutes she's an
[__] bro it obviously obviously she's
let's get down to the nitty green so
right I'll try and read it fast bill my
girlfriend for two years we get on in
all this aspects other than how much I
see or talk to my son she's 28 I'm 34 my
son is 14 years old
old boy 14 years old silent force there
let's pause there first of all when they
met he would have been at least seven to
you the you would have been at least
seven cuz it's not how you now she
they've been together two years so
exactly so he was 12 the youth was 12
said he was tough so she knew he had to
you yeah
from day so why is she now complaining I
don't know but sons 14 sadly stays at
his mum's usually I see him every day
but during the current circumstances I
can't usually yeah usually picks him up
from school so around in the evening
around 7 p.m. our facetiming for 30
minutes to 45 minutes and will do his
schoolwork to give a chat about rhino
[__] talk about gaming strategies etc
gang my girlfriend's getting really
upset about this because she says I'm
taking up a lot of time on him and that
she wants us to eat dinner to give her
at 7 I told her that was ok and I would
push back my FaceTime and calls to 4:00
p.m. then I know my son's home from
school but his mum says that's not a
good idea because he has online classes
I said okay cool I'll FaceTime an 8 I
said said that's not good because he
goes to go out in the garden with his
stepdad and watch the sunset
so basically 7 PM's the only time that
works I asked my girlfriend if it'd be
okay if we ate dinner at 8:00 she said
no she didn't give me a reason
I told she was being unfair to me
because I need to juggle my son's
happiness a vital time I'm trying to
make her happy to preach and since both
of us are working from home at the
moment our schedules are all messed up
and inna 8 p.m. isn't too out of the
ordinary for us needless to say
my girlfriend said I was being selfish
and Romaic and they wouldn't hurt to
tell my son no 8:00 p.m. is better for
me because standing in the garden
looking at the sky is a weak excuse to
not want that time utilized big man this
is such an easy oh isn't such a
no-brainer oh I'm dumping you in a
[__] spa trap
what do you mean tell my son no cuz now
staring at the sky is not I'm not
telling him nothing if he wants to die
he wants to watch [__] gay are
sunsets every night we can do it
obviously eyebrow he didn't do his step
that he can do by himself but that's
what if that's what he wants to just the
rags to steal is such an she's a
[__] fact they both what setup they
both sleep together in the same bed they
both work from homestead I've always at
home all day every day anyway regardless
you have to work whatever but you're
still in the company of your partner
once you finish work out five or
whatever you've got five to seven to do
whatever you want to do in me because
I'm speaking to my son at seven family
have to move some [__] around you're
gonna have to move some [__] because I'm
keeping my schedule the same film
because so you are the awesome that's
why is such an [__] it doesn't even
make sense he shouldn't have even needed
to ask
it doesn't entertain that conversation a
lot you ever my man if you ever listened
to this big man you are not the oh so
she's the also you need to look that go
get your son bro is with the with
partners and stuff for that is such a
weird one when the kids get involved
like any opinion that your other half
has about your kid it's a it's a cut up
thing it's tough it's like are you sure
you want to go look it's such a
sensitive you know I'm gonna pick my
unity so are you really ready for that
bro that's the question he picks up is
you from school on a normal day every
single day nah bro and I'm facetiming
for 45 minutes and you're telling me no
look we can't eat dinner at eight
waiting you're my fam I'm eating dinner
at eight put it away when I want it you
dinner
Robbie it's about you I'm speaking to my
you you knew I had a you before you got
me bro you knew what it was when you met
me knew what it was you know it could
have potentially been so why go through
that why put yourself through that
tell your son looking at the sky is a
weak excuse weak I'll bang him in your
face
um we're pretty corrupt American up
there
and then pack your [__] and find
somewhere else to stay because because
this ain't working for me if you just
establish your [__] oh I can't I
couldn't bear that if you don't eat at
8:00 then bye
oh yeah if anyone disagrees with which
you Betty card oh I really disagree you
cause you can't disagree but if you do
hit the comments brand let me know
before you even contemplate disagreeing
because I know you women out there yeah
let's let's flip it let's say it was her
you that was staying at the dads let's
say she let's say she saw her you like
every weekend but now she's she's with
another guy and her actual kids like her
first kids are with the father that
lives somewhere else so ever and she's
the one that's trying to FaceTime her
kid and blah blah every day but the
husband are looking the new partner said
no let's change that blah how would you
feel before you flip it and say are
wearing the wrong what he's all wrong
how would you feel if she was the one
trying to FaceTime her child when she's
got a new partner and her new partner
saying oh we need to eat at 7 o'clock
because this than any other even and
trying to try and say that's what I'm
trying to FaceTime I mean she's a fool
and it's not even I she's [__] 18
years old she's 28 years of age big
woman says oh it's not a drama team you
wanna have any way rapping about yeah
man then before you guys go obviously
mid corona stay safe stay at home oh
yeah be healthy you know keep listening
to the podcast my guys keep listening to
the podcast we're gonna keep going and
go when I go in and go in yeah man love
was easy